احتجاجات غاضبه لاهالي السويداء تعود بقوه
وتواجهها قوات الامن السوري بالرصاص وتقتل
متظاهر في واقعه هي الاولى منذ سنوات
المرصده السوري قال ان مئات المواطنين في
المدينه احتجوا على تدهور الاوضاع
المعيشيه وعدم تامين المستلزمات ومستلزمات
الحياه الضروريه في المدينه وتمكنوا من
اقتحام مبنى المحافظه جانب ازاله صوره
بشار الاسد المعلقه في واجهه المبنى ما
ادى لهرب الموظفين من الباب ده في ظل توتر
امني شديد في المدينه واحياء هذه المدينه
فيما اطلقت قوات النظام الرصاص تجاه
المتظاهرين امام مبنى المحافظه ومبنى
قياده الشرطه وسط المدينه ما اسفل ذلك عن
وقوع قتيل وعدد من الاصابات في صفوفهم اما
اعلام النظام السوري فوصف المحتجين في
السويداء همم في الجنوب الشرقيه من سوريا
بانهم مجموعه من الهاربين من العداله وقال
انهم احرقوا وثائق رسميه ونشرت شبكات
محليه سوريه صورا وتسجيلات مصوره لمحتاجين
اثناء التدمير سياره امنيه كما نشاهدون
محمله برشاش بعد دخولها في صفوفهم اضافه
لاحراق عربه مصفحه تابعه للنظام في محيط
مبنى السرايا الحكوميه تعبيرا طبعا عن
الغضب الشعبي
[تصفيق]
ابعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام
عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]